i try to
always be true to the character of peter
parker deal with him honestly like in
any dramatic motion picture sometimes in
the comic book movies
they take a step back from reality
even when dealing with the characters
but i decided to take a different
approach and
make it as real as possible so that the
audience believed that they could
believe in this hero in this man the
best way to watch a horror movie i think
is to see it in a full crowd
because
you get this energy going
where the audience
collectively gets afraid and it spreads
throughout the crowd like wildfire if
it's working there are two schools of
thought i think for horror filmmakers
one is that the audience can always
create something more horrible than you
can show them and the other school of
thought is show them show them show them
everything people what people are really
interested in is the story of people the
simplest things are often usually the
best my advice to a young filmmaker is
to make a movie every week right every
night and every weekend shoot for two
days and work with actors cut those
scenes together and get a response and
get a response from the audience and see
where it's slow and where it doesn't
work and your ideas weren't being
communicated properly the worst thing
the worst crime i think that filmmakers
can make is to make a boring picture
because if it's boring then
it's all over the audience you've failed
in entertaining them
you've committed a crime
[Music]
is the budget important for the quality
of the movie
well you can make a great movie as i'm
sure everybody knows for very little
money
um if you people what people are really
interested in is the story of people
uh the dramatics that happen between a
man and a woman or two men or
um the simplest things are often usually
the best there are two schools of
thought i think for horror filmmakers
one is that the audience can always
create something more horrible than you
can show them and the other school of
thought is show them show them show them
everything and i believe that both is
true i believe the audience can come up
with something more horrible in their
minds than i can show them provided
they're given the raw materials to
construct something
and i also believe that i have got some
pretty horrible things to show myself so
i try and mix and match i try and scare
them and
weird them out with visuals and i try
and leave room for them to add their own
ingredients to create one of the things
that we learned from
our repeated visits to the horror
picture
were certain laws that happen to apply
to all horror pictures
and that is
the innocent must suffer
the poor sap who walks into the house
has to be tormented
and then the next law came into uh
we came to realize there was a second
law governing all horror pictures and
that was the guilty must be punished
whatever evil thing there is out there
whatever dark force there is the
audience wants to see their hero lay
into it pretty pretty intensely
and then
we found there was a third law and that
is that you must taste blood to be a man
you've got to go through this
uh in these horror films this uh
coming of age uh through this this blood
experience
uh now joel and ethan cohen have
mentioned that a fourth law exists
that the dead must walk but we're still
uh
we're still testing that law in our
research labs to see if it holds true in
all cases on the one side it is an
action movie and visually very rich and
on the other side it's a love story how
did you balance this
well i tried to
always be true to the character of peter
parker
and
deal with him honestly like in any
dramatic motion picture sometimes in the
comic book movies
they take a step back from reality
even when dealing with the characters
but i decided to take a different
approach and
make it as real as possible so that the
audience believed that they could
believe in this hero in this man
and
that was really my guide all the way
through the performance pieces my advice
to a young filmmaker is to make a movie
every week right every night
and every weekend shoot for two days and
work with actors work with a little 1000
watt lighting kit set it up set up your
shots get a tripod
shoot a little scene work with the
actors cut those scenes together and
then the next weekend
have worked on it with sound and looping
and put some music to it it can all be
done for nothing nowadays with the
computer
and get a response and get a response
from the audience and see where it's
slow and where it doesn't work and your
ideas weren't being communicated
properly learn from that experience
sitting in with the crowd then go out
make another picture the next weekend
and just keep doing it make films no
matter what anybody says and you'll be a
filmmaker it's wonderful to have a
villain in the second picture we you've
got can see his face see their face
emoting expressing
whatever they're feeling
alfred's a great actor and we really
needed somebody with that strong sense
of um reality and somebody with a sense
of humor which alfred has this character
doc ock the way that alfred is creating
him
um
he's really uh a human being a
misunderstood
man
who becomes a beast so what are like
three tips you think for like the good
harp um
let's see
keep in suspense um
deliver the scares
and try and delve into
the unknown things that really scare you
and bring a little bit of that forth
into the picture first of all we've seen
an influx of
the man versus nature films but
generally they're done in a sort of
cheesy tongue-in-cheek way yeah this is
not
what was the
basis to to take it seriously to
actually make it scary again
should we go yes i think alex recognized
in the rasmussen brothers script
that the real power lied in the fact
that it really could happen and so he
took a very realistic approach to his
cgi effects to the performances that he
directed to
everything that he did and um
that's i think why the film is so
effective is
that it doesn't exaggerate it's not
about a giant creature that couldn't
exist it really is a set of
circumstances that could
and i think that's what makes it so
scary i forget you are a big fan of the
marvel comics spider-man how did you
feel when you knew you'd be making a
film
i was absolutely terrified
i got a call
and they told me i was going to be
directing the film
and uh i had no idea how i was ever
going to do that
they had a start date
the script was in not great shape and i
had no idea how i was ever going to
bring off
what i thought all the fans must have
been expecting this great aerial ballet
this graceful movement of spider-man
swooping to the city of manhattan
through the canyons and
it had to be done with great grace and
agility
his movements had to be incredibly fluid
and beautiful to look at
i just didn't know i didn't have a clue
how we're gonna do it it's never easy to
do the right thing so that's why i like
the spider-man movie that we're making
now because it's um
it's about
choices and it shows
not like a message movie but it shows
how we can all make these choices how
will he weigh his
personal needs
against his sense of responsibility
you